election day it's an opportunity to
celebrate our democracy but some people
very very fearful but fearful rather
about what might happen
after the results come in think about
that for just a second now we should
stress
officials are not aware of any specific
threat but many businesses taking no
chances across the country they are
boarding up
just in case a new steel fence went up
around the white house yesterday
and police are preparing for the
possibility of unrest regardless of the
election's outcome
lead national correspondent david begno
is in midtown
with more on this story david good
morning to you people very very nervous
the streets so eerie this morning
they are a little quiet but bustling as
people are starting to get out to go to
work and hopefully go to vote gayle take
a look behind me the
famous macy's flagship store is all
boarded up with plywood
and we've noticed this morning more and
more businesses as we hear sirens in the
background
have started to board up they don't want
a repeat of what we saw during the
george floyd protests where peaceful
protesters were in some cases
overshadowed
by looters looking to make trouble some
businesses have hired private security
they've taken in the extra chairs and
table for outdoor dining
so that people can't use them as
projectiles to break glass
new york city and for that matter the
country is on edge today
from los angeles to denver
to raleigh and to new york
business owners are boarding up
embracing for election night
this year the tensions are high from
anger over coronavirus restrictions
to large protests about police brutality
the protests calling for racial justice
were mostly peaceful
but marred by violence from agitators
what have you guys done
we've just brought it up over the
weekend in preparation for
what may or may not happen after the
election
jim english is the general manager of
warehouse wines and spirits here in
manhattan
his store was looted during protests
earlier this year following the death of
george floyd
how much damage was there it was almost
200 000
with the damage i did not feel
particularly safe then
i don't think that they could allow that
same response to happen again
without people in the city just saying
like i don't feel safe
so i hope that they are modern situation
in the days following the election
we will have additional offices ready to
respond
to any type of incident the new york
police department says it will work with
40 agencies to monitor activity from its
joint operations center on monday
vandals targeted the democratic party
headquarters in houston texas
spray painting the windows with the
words elections no
revolution yes fbi officials will be
monitoring tonight's developments from a
command center
inside fbi headquarters there was an
independent report that found
five states are especially at risk for
civilian militia activity this week
including the state of oregon the
governor says the national guard
is on standby we stand here today urging
all oregonians to commit to non-violent
expression we can all do our parts this
week
by staying calm cool and collected
hope this makes you feel comfortable cbs
news has been told by federal law
enforcement sources there is no
direct threat about violence surrounding
the election however
law enforcement officials are concerned
that if the election becomes
contested that looters and agitators
could then come in
and disrupt what would be otherwise
peaceful protests yeah anthony back to
you
and we hope it's a peaceful day david
thank you very much line's already
forming at my polling station at 5 30
a.m so people not discouraged